welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition I'm Parag Khanna joined by a
distinguished panel including Gumby
samoy Oh Daniel Altman and uh none gerd
heartless China is it just the dragon of
global growth or is it a drag on global
growth and I think this is a very
worthwhile question to be asking because
even though China represents a huge
percentage of the global economic growth
and a growing share of the global
economy it's not necessarily doing it in
all fairways well there's fairness and
then there are just economic impacts I
think China has had one big impact on
poor countries around the world which is
it's very hard to climb the economic
ladder the way you used to which is by
moving through it from agriculture into
low-cost manufacturing because China
dominates that in a way no other country
can you have to look for much more niche
industries now but China is also
investing a lot in countries around the
world the question is are its
investments having sustainable long-term
benefits for the communities where they
do business and a lot of people would
say that they're not the other thing
it's doing in a lot of developing
countries whether we like it or not is
creating a competition of models
political models it hasn't really
existed in a very serious way for
hundreds of years where in a number of
countries in the world in Africa Latin
America etc people are genuinely asking
whether the Chinese system or the
something like the American system is
better for their country hermocrates
aren't some of these same emerging
markets saying China is actually
becoming a problem for us because they
subsidize their industries and they
manipulate their currency and therefore
even though we are growing Africa is
growing Latin America's growing they
could actually be growing even more if
it weren't for China actually out
competing them I think that's much more
of a developed country argument against
China I mean certainly their issues you
think of China and Africa there are
certainly issues around labor laws were
on environmental concerns but
fundamentally the amount of investment
that has gone into Africa into South
America even into Australia which is the
largest foreign direct investment
recipient from China is clearly
beneficial you know you look at a place
like Africa which is a billion people
represents just two percent of the world
trade it's less than the trade of Spain
I mean the fact that now China
desperately needs to purchase African
agriculture goods is a real opportunity
for economic growth with these eco
economy something that we haven't seen
in a long time but this can put them
to trouble too because if trying to
start handing out billion dollar checks
to buy up farms or other resources in
poor countries that don't have very good
governments that money is going to
disappear and then what happens when
there's a food shortage the people in
that country going to turn around say
we're not going to let the Chinese March
off with all of our resources when we
didn't receive any benefit in return
we're going to renegotiate these deals
we're going to take it back and that's
going to create a new risk both for that
country and for China and so there could
be blowback which would be very
interesting because China has really
come center stage as a world superpower
but it hasn't yet experienced below back
in any of these interventions or any of
these roles it's absolutely and what in
what you're talking about essentially is
one of the most brilliant strategies of
the Chinese have implemented which is
this idea of symbiosis it's not just in
the emerging world they've done exactly
the same thing in the United States
they've lent money to the United States
and return have gotten access to
precisely what America does in terms of
resources which is the American consumer
I also think this something very
patronizing in a way about a lot of the
way we talk about China in this country
which is a complete amnesia about what
we were like when we were a country at
China's level of GDP trying to kind of
flex our muscles in the world stage for
the first time being a little maladroit
about that doing a lot of shady deals
having a lot of corrupt people in our
country and then you clean it up as
development goes on hopefully I
sometimes think we're very unethical out
of the countries who are on a fairly
similar road are going through well but
think about a former economic superpower
that used to do things very differently
and I'm thinking of the USSR they would
make big investments around the world in
the countries that they hope to
cultivate his client States but they
always built capacity because they
wanted to make the sharpest and strong
as possible bonds that they could with
those countries they helped those people
in those countries to learn new
professions to have the capacity to grow
on their own and that's where I think
China's falling down a little bit it
gets a sign of just how central China
has become to the global economy that we
can have so many different perspectives
on exactly what that role is going to be
and how it's going to evolve but one
thing is for sure China is absolutely
going to be central to the future of
economic competition thanks so much for
your insights more on China global
economic competition and other topics at
big thang com
you